yako ma copine c'est quoi tuer le palu
on dirait que oui je veux aller voir un
moment tout à l'heure pour calmer soigne
et paris 4e grand rendez vous avez ces
bêtas des levées décidément les
nouvelles vont vite dans ce quartier où
tu t'inquiètes pourquoi même on sait que
c'était pour couvrir bintou je sais qu'à
yop city là il faut avoir peur de la
bouche des gentilles un signe que ma
bouche qui disent ah tu habib sy tout et
c'est quoi en ce moment elle doit être
en pleines négociations pour son avenir
un bon où elle est bien on va avoir du
travail alors les filles et mamadou je
passais par là c'est gentil de venu me
rendre visite
tu connais aia oui ça va ya bon je vais
partir à deux jours déjà
attends je vais te pousser jusqu'à la
peau tu as it mamadou qui arrive c'est
pas un gain de bintou celui là oui mais
comme elle est séquestrée ils s'ennuient
alors il vient me voir
ah parce que tu es comédienne à ses
heures perdues tu distrait les gens
aillent à tu veux dire quoi comme ça un
de m'embrouiller ton français
mais pourquoi tu te fâche c'est papa là
je crois que quoi que c'est toi c'est
elle qui a la cb de tout le cas type par
le groupe français compliqué de pause -
wedge situe toujours malade la face voir
ma vieille salut c'est sa salle